way menopause has been branded is you're
old you're done that's not it yeah
you're old you're done your vagina is
dry yeah you have no value in society
anymore you're not attractive you're not
attractive it's like cobwebs down there
yeah you're not okay that's not true
also also the other thing Nikki is you
don't have to have drastic symptoms
not everybody has these kind of symptoms
I know some women who they've been
through it and they've just sort of
sailed to it have had very minimal
things it wasn't disruptive to their
life that was not my experience but my
mother also had very bad symptoms but
she never talked about listen